- [Narrator] If you're looking to save
as much money as possible
when filing your taxes this year,
knowing this one number will help.
Your adjusted gross income or AGI.
- Adjusted gross income
is the starting point
for your tax return.
It's a common measure of
income that the IRS uses
and the government uses to
determine how much money
you've made over the
course of the past year.
- [Narrator] So to
demystify your tax return,
we break down how to calculate your AGI
and how this one number
impacts your finances.
(mellow music)
The IRS defines adjusted
gross income, or AGI,
as your gross income minus
adjustments to income.
It's commonly referred to as the line.
Above the line, you have two things.
Your gross income and your adjustments.
Your gross income is a
combination of your wages,
stock dividends, capital gains
and any other income you might
have, like business profits.
Adjustments refer to things
like interest on student loan payments,
contributions to some retirement accounts
and expenses you may have as
a teacher, just to name a few.
These adjustments are commonly referred to
as above the line deductions.
And once you subtract them
from your gross income,
you've got your AGI.
So once you've calculated
it, why does it matter?
Let's take a look at Olivia
and calculate her gross income.
Olivia earned $60,000 a year
from her day job as a chemist.
After subtracting her 401K contributions
and health insurance
premiums, which aren't taxed,
her taxable wage is $57,000 a year.
She also rented out her extra bedroom,
which brought in a net total of $6,000.
And lastly, Olivia bought and sold stocks
within the past year, profiting $1000.
Because she held the stocks
for only a few months,
her profit is considered
a short term capital gain
and is taxed at the ordinary income rate,
meaning it's less
complicated for our purposes.
So all together, Olivia's gross
income comes out to $64,000.
But remember, if you have
other sources of income,
like from freelancing or side hustles,
you'll need to add those to
your gross income as well.
Now, to find Olivia's AGI,
she has to subtract the
adjustments from her gross income.
There are quite a few possibilities here
like educator expenses and
self-employed health insurance.
One of those adjustments is
interest on student loan debt.
Olivia has private student loan debt
and made payments throughout the year,
so she can subtract up to $2,500,
bringing her AGI to $61,500.
This brings us back to why knowing
your adjusted gross income matters.
After your AGI has been calculated,
you can check for any tax
credits you may qualify for.
- Adjusted gross income
is used by Congress
to set parameters for various tax breaks
to basically ensure that they're going to
lower and middle income people
and then aren't fully available
to very high income people.
- [Narrator] There are a lot
of tax credits available.
- For example, you have something
called the saver's credit
which is essentially a government match
for retirement contributions
and you have the earned income credit
which is the government's main program
for assisting low and
middle income families.
- [Narrator] Last year,
31 million eligible workers and families
benefited from the
earned income tax credit,
averaging savings of more than $2,000.
There are also tax credits
with eligibility tied to AGI
for students and parents,
like the American Opportunity Tax Credit
or Child Tax Credit.
But these situations
don't apply to Olivia,
so she doesn't get to claim tax breaks
based on AGI this year.
After you calculate your tax credits,
you can take deductions and
determine your actual tax bill.
- The more you understand
about how the tax code works,
how it keys off of this number,
the easier it can be to figure out
why you're getting to the bottom
line number you're getting.
- [Narrator] If you hire an accountant
or use other tax services,
you may not need to calculate your AGI
to figure out how to save with it.
But no matter whether your
taxes are in your hands
or someone else's, this
little number on line 11
plays a key role in your financial life.